on a sunbathe hilltop in Central Los
Angeles sits a picturesque home turned
headquarters
it's where three friends became business
partners over a shared philosophy if you
are strong and need something strong so
strong women strong yeah for singer
luckily Geena karela Yeti and Yola
Jimenez that strong drink has long been
yola's family recipe of miss kau a
Mexican spirit known for its smoky
flavor they say it filled a void in the
already crowded liquor industry so they
bottled it and Yola miss Cal was born
everything in the market was steered
toward partying or the guy after his
heart day of work in his big leather
chair with his big watch you know and it
was sort of like all of our friends and
all of our generation are wearing the
pants they're the breadwinners of their
homes they have to work and we want to
have our big glass of something strong
at the end of the day their recipe was
developed in part by yola's grandfather
back in 1971 when he died and I wanted
to take over the farm you could see the
women working everywhere but you have to
talk to a man to make the final
decisions who is of course infuriating
so from the beginning I kept telling
Gina Leakey about how women in Oaxaca
were doing everything and we went
together to the farm and said well we
should focus on is having a brand that's
for them done by them
yo Namaskar listen a little familiar
that's when the friends decided their
myths Cal would have a message support
the women who make it in Mexico by
ensuring they're paid directly this is
of course about a great product from
Oaxaca which is a mezcal but it's mostly
about what is it that we can do that can
change a little bit a little bit the
world
you may not have heard of mezcal but
it's been slowly seeping into cocktails
and trendy bars for years miss Cal is
made by distilling more than 30
varieties of the pineapple looking plant
agave tequila is actually a type of
mezcal made only from blue agave but
unlike most Aquila typical miss cow is
often made by hand and in small batches
it always had the connotation of being a
poor indigenous drink and it was only
until people were becoming interested in
organic products things were done
locally and with a rich tradition that
miss Custer become famous in Mexico and
then he had an explosion as at the
former - when I tour I'm always looking
to like you need a little bit of
something to get going and I was a huge
whisky fan but I would lose my voice
every night so when I drank my skull you
get this high but there's no come down
to combine her passions and help spread
the brand's message she led the launch
of yo la dia all-female music festival
that raises money for ghen ization 'he's
like the aclu and an LA Women's Center
using music to promote female
empowerment was a natural next step you
know even in all the music festivals or
all the shows like the female headliners
are so few and all the people working
behind the stage and in production all
of that is male so then we decided that
it was a good idea to do it to only have
female headliners players security
guards production talent like in the
food everything the festival sold out
and anotherís planned for this summer
just tastes so delicious the mascot they
might make it look easy with their
stylized branding and laser focused
mission but starting a liquor company
with no industry experience was tough
men in the industry were a little bit of
Earth to us in the beginning we need
something lighter they're not as sturdy
as a man that's not true we can handle
ourselves so I have a dirty little
secret okay I don't okay well we're
gonna get started right now we waited
until we got to the bar
aptly named bar restaurant for the taste
test no pressure
do people drink just miss Gail neat yes
[Laughter]
this one's different yeah okay
beginning just a kiss well that is good
it's not as smoky as I'm used to how do
you feel
Adriana I'm with you guys before it's
good and with every pore there's a
larger purpose improve lives in Mexico
one drink at a time what do you think
your grandfather for to think if he
could taste this he would be ecstatic
oh he's five what he wanted to do was
try to make a difference in Oaxaca I
hope from wherever he is he's looking at
this moment and he's smiling for CBS
this morning Saturday 8:00 ideas Los
Angeles